With just one year to go, anticipation is
building across the District as Stadium Waimakariri
starts to take shape.
The Mayor and Councillors toured the site
last week alongside staff from the North Canterbury
Sport & Recreation Trust who will be responsible
for managing the facility
once construction is complete.
Mayor Dan Gordon says it was wonderful to
be able to walk through the building and get
a sense of what the finished Stadium will
be like.
It's really good to come through and have a
sneak preview of where this project is at.
As we can see a lot of people have been talking
about it as they've gone past on Coldstream
Road and seen the framing go up.
It's looking fantastic, I understand it's
well on track and the contractors are certainly
making a good job of it as we can see.
It's going to be a terrific asset to our community
this facility.
Four courts with all the other services that
will be here including a gymnasium as well.
So it's good to see progress and it's good
see the contractors are doing such a good
job on behalf of our community.
The $28 million multi-use sports facility
will be approximately 6,000 square metres
in size and house four indoor courts, as well
as a central fitness facility, changing rooms,
coaching and meeting spaces and seating for
up to 500 spectators.
Designed by Warren and Mahoney architects,
it aims to become a vibrant focus point for
sport in the District.
The Stadium can also easily be expanded in
the future if required.
The site on Coldstream Road places it near
other sporting grounds such as the MainPower
Oval, MainPower Hockey Turf and Maria Andrews
Park.
Despite a small delay due to the Covid-19
lockdown, construction is on schedule.
It’s expected that the Stadium’s doors
will open to the public towards the end of July 2021.